elle a désormais pignon sur rue dans
l'univers du livre la bd s'est même fait
une place au soleil dans les rayons rien
que pour cette année on dénombre entre 5
et 6000 nouveautés sur le marché
c'est une immersion dans le monde du 9e
art à l'échelle régionale
une histoire de bulles normande en
quatre épisodes bayeux et sa place aux
pommes c'est là que nous avons rendez
vous avec jérôme et au voilà six ans
maintenant que ce dessinateur originaire
de l'île de france à poser ses crayons
dans le bessin entre deux allers retours
à la capitale il intervient également au
plan local dans le milieu associatif
comme ici pour 3 18
l'idée de faire des interventions avec
des jeunes dont on est quand même
quelques-uns à le faire après certains
dessinateurs transmettre au travers de
leur naissance à leur suffit moi j'ai
besoin d'avoir ce
ce contact cette rencontre ne serait ce
que pour être sûr que que je tape à côté
est-ce qu'il y en a parmi vous qui aime
bien dessinés plus particulièrement la
team des futurs mangaka dans
l'assistance on raconte ses histoires
pour soi on se dessine souvent pour soi
et on veut les offrir aux autres doigts
donc si on raconte des choses qui sont
pas du tout en phase avec son lectorat
ça ça sert à rien quoi dans la bulle aux
ferrer au il y un mot à la fois léger et
lourd de sens la citoyenneté
depuis des années maintenant le coauteur
des petits citoyen fait de la bd sur
planche et sur toile un véritable outil
d'expression civique
[Musique]
les hommes ont le droit après la
naissance de leur enfant de prendre du
temps pour s'en occuper
c'est bien vrai ça ce n'est pas réservé
qu'aux mamans travail et celle de
souhaite c'est ça on se partage les
tâches
moi je me sers de mon de mon petit
graphique pour passer des fois des
messages qui sont à ses fins pas dur
mais en tout cas qui interpellent et qui
peuvent ouvrir le débat
l'idée c'est de se dire qu'est ce qu'il
faut qu'on fasse pour qu on vivre bien
ensemble et que ça soit en bonne
intelligence et que chacun avec ses
idées qui sont pas forcément les mêmes à
la base
eh ben on puisse cohabiter avec nos
vérités respectifs
on commence par un plan un grand plan
large comme dans un film
là où va se dérouler l'action ce qui
compte c'est pas de savoir dessiner
comme des dieux c'est pas être les
meilleurs et c'est d'avoir l'envi quelle
qu'elle soit est déjà intervenu sur
après justement les événements de
charlie hebdo pour travailler un petit
peu sur la caricature donc ses premiers
décrets qu'on avait fait avec lui donc
on avait travaillé sur la caricature
pour une première approche pour savoir
que c'était aussi
voilà qui avaient des dessinateurs qui
existait dans la région de bayeux et
donc il était une première fois et
ensuite il est revenu d'autrefois pour
travailler avec est entré on fidélise
comme sont en général quand ça marche
bien et pas bien pour moi c'est un
artiste à part entière
parce qu'il peut y avoir des artistes
qui vont qui vendent plus d'albums tout
ça mais jérôme lui là il ya un petit
truc où ils arrivent à être en contact
directement avec les gens il n'ya pas de
problème
c'est ça qui qui fait qu' on a tous
envie de se dire il est génial ce gars
mais on a tout de suite envie d'être
avec lui c'est c'est un artiste il vend
du rêve un clairement il vend du rêve
changeait rien et garonne merci
[Musique]